interdimensional portals badass warriors
and josephine baker episode 7 of
lovecraft country is here and
holy crap was this a trip in this video
we'll be taking a deep dive into the
episode and explaining some of the cool
things you may have missed along the way
including the time machine diana's comic
and the meaning behind hippolyta's
journey
so make sure to like and subscribe so
you're notified as soon as one of my
videos comes out
and two quick disclaimers one i haven't
read the book so you won't get any
spoilers here
and two this show deals heavily with
issues of racial injustice so if i've
gotten something wrong
please leave me a comment or dm me oh
god i'm already getting flashbacks of
grade 12 calculus
hippolyta is here trying to unlock hiram
epstein's orrery which she took from
letty's house back in episode 3.
she's come back from the ruins of artem
where she found a burnt copy of d's
comic arithia blue
at the end of episode 4 hippolyta and d
found george's map which circled devon
county the location where artem is
located
and where george died she's been
suspicious of
letty montrose and atticus's story about
his death
and goes to investigate the burnt comic
was proof that he was there as it was
given to george as a going away present
from d in episode one we'll see
hippolyta become arithia blue over the
course of her journey an
interplanetary discoverer who rides a
spaceship which we'll also see
hippolyta even wears blue among the
artem ruins
she's able to unlock the ori which has a
key and inscription
every beginning is in time and every
limit of extension in space
along with some coordinates now we'll
see coordinates on the bottom left-hand
side of the screen throughout the
episode which denotes latitude longitude
and a third which i'm
i'm not a ferdinand magellan over here
but i'm guessing that's the
z-axis which denotes a specific point in
time
or 3d space you can actually go into
google maps and insert these first two
coordinates like i did here the
coordinates found on the orary lead to a
small field outside kansas city
which is likely the location of the
winthrop observatory where hippolyta
ends up now this isn't the first time
this observatory has been mentioned
in episode 5 when ruby finds herself in
the closet we hear captain lancaster and
his men
talk about how they made a deal with the
local sheriff's department to look
after the place hence why two policemen
show up later in the episode christina
shows ruby what's in her basement
the bodies of william and hillary who
she's been using to concoct her
shape-shifting potions
ruby is pissed that christina used her
but christina says her feelings toward
her were real
the words may have come out of william's
mouth
they were mine i'm not exactly sure we
can take christina's word here after all
she'll likely end up using ruby to gain
access to letty's house which she can't
get into because of the force field
christina has lied
cheated and killed her own father to
prove herself so if she has to hurt
ruby in order to get what she wants she
won't think twice
letty has a dream featuring atticus's
ancestor hannah the same one who escaped
artem with the book of names
letty is likely pregnant here later
getting nauseous at the smell of garlic
something
she used to love and it's no wonder this
pregnancy lines up with her first stream
of hannah since she now
technically has the blood of adam
flowing through the child within her
atticus has been unable to sleep after
the mysterious die message he translated
at the end of episode
5. he tells letty that hannah must have
had the whole book of names but he
doesn't know where to find it since most
of his mom's side was killed in the
tulsa massacre
montrose wakes up to breakfast from
sammy but things
quickly turn cold when montro snaps back
to reality he can't have his neighbors
knowing he's a gay man and pushes sammy
away
ultimately leading him to the hallway
where he's discovered by atticus and
letty
tree hinted to atticus that his father
might be gay but now atticus knows it to
be true
even calling him the f word in anger as
a child
montrose beat up atticus mercilessly so
that he quote
wouldn't be soft as he explains to letty
he now understands these beatings were
never about him
more so about his father taking out his
pain on his son
ruby and letty look after dee while
hippolyta goes in search of her own
answers
snubbing atticus and letty who she knows
weren't telling the truth about george
dee also declines to go over the travel
checklist something she used to do with
george
letty apologizes to ruby about not
telling her about their mother's
inheritance which she used to buy the
home
money which was actually from christina
braithwight ruby has been withholding
the fact she's been romantically linked
with christina
so it's gonna be real interesting how
this all pans out on her way to the
observatory hippolyta encounters a woman
riding a blue motorcycle this is a nod
to iconic motorcyclist bessie
stringfield
who is the first black woman to ride
solo through all 48 u.s mainland states
including the jim crow south this scene
evokes a feeling of freedom which
becomes a main theme for hippolyta in
this episode atticus tracks down miss
oberta a friend of his mother's cousin
ethel we don't really get a lot of new
info here just that he discovers a photo
of a woman with the same birthmark he
has
on his back we don't get a name for who
this is miss alberta simply says
guess who this is but it doesn't look
like his mother so my guess is that it's
his cousin
ethel letty ends up calling atticus to
tell him hippolyta has the ori meaning
she's likely in danger whatever she's up
to
it's also important to note that ruby is
watching this happen
whether this is because she's spying for
christina we're not exactly sure
hippolyta arrives at the observatory
where she's able to get the machine to
work before two of lancaster's men
arrive
atticus has somehow made his way there
in record time and is able to throw
one of the men in an interdimensional
portal before he and hippolyta
herself are sucked into different times
we get more coordinates here even though
we're either in the
super far future or super far past but
my guess is that we're in the future
since we see these robot-like entities
the coordinates here are the same as the
observatory location near kansas city
however as we get more and more of these
coordinates a lot of them don't show up
on google maps
it's either because i'm putting them in
wrong or that location doesn't exist in
google maps
perhaps because it's a different point
in time if you're interested in all the
locations and where they exist in
relation to one another and maybe want
to try it out for yourself
check out the link i've left in the
description to sheriff of baddie's post
who has a breakdown hippolyta is taken
to this futuristic prison cell where her
captor billed in the credits as
serafina aka beyond say a play on words
for beyonce
holds her prisoner she even has these
metaphorical shackles on her wrist
something serafina removes from her when
she's completed her journey and that's
because hippolyta doesn't realize she's
enslaved it isn't until she completes
her journey that she's truly free
she sets forth through time where she
meets josephine baker
and if you don't know who she is i
highly suggest you look into her not
only was she a headline dancer for the
biggest reviews in paris
she was the first black woman to star in
a major motion picture in 1927
she aided the french resistance in world
war ii and contributed heavily to the
civil rights movement in the united
states
where she was offered unofficial
leadership following martin luther king
jr's assassination
it's by tasting this freedom hippolyta
realizes how society as
gretchen smale of bustle puts it molded
herself into the perfect stereotype an
obedient and differential housewife who
rarely objected to being trampled
on and discovered that all i ever was
was the exact
kind of negro woman white folks wanted
me to be
i feel like they just found a smart way
to lynch me without me noticing the
noose
the first step in her journey is about
her realizing how she is enslaved maybe
not like her ancestors were with
physical shackles but a new form of
slavery she's even honest with herself
telling josephine that
sometimes i just i want to kill white
folks
just like she did before she entered the
portal but the person she's most angry
at is herself
hate me but letting them make me feel
small
also bonus points if you notice the
quick cameo of mexican painter frida
kahlo
a woman whose work explored questions of
gender race and post-colonialism so
hippolyta now has this
pent-up anger something she learns to
harness in the second part of her
journey
where she travels to a tribe of warrior
women heavily based off the amino
also known as the dahomey amazons they
were an all-female military regiment in
what is now present-day republic of
benin it's here this modern day slavery
which he learned in part one
is expanded on by a warrior named nawi
she explains how even though they are
technically free they still
cook the white man's food raise their
children and work for them
if she's going to overcome this new
slavery she must fight
and fight she does as the tribe takes on
a group of confederate soldiers i've
heard a few people say they're not
confederates rather white colonizers
like the french legionnaires but take a
look at this side-by-side photo of these
uniforms i think it's pretty clear
they're confederates
the last line before hippolyta moves on
to the next part of her journey is very
important
george's life her identity as a person
is still shackled to that of a man
it's only until she confronts him in the
final scene how she realizes
george kept her small she gave up her
dreams of discovery to be the obedient
housewife like
society had conditioned her to be she
even says
when i was a kid i thought i was big
enough to have every right to name
something out of this world which is a
callback to the story she told dee in
the planetarium about
how she discovered a comet but didn't
get credit for it because she was black
her confrontation with george allows her
to fully realize who she
is not hippolyta george's wife but
hippolyta the discoverer just like
arithia blue the shackles binding her to
george
dissipate and the two go on the final
part of her journey as
equals discovering new planets and
species jazz musician and poet sunra's
words
speak in the background talking about
how black people are a myth because they
have no equal rights
no status among the nations hippolyta is
now free and welcome to join
seraphina in her society but she chooses
not to instead
learning that it may be too late for her
to achieve what she wants but it's not
too late for dee
she'll head back to earth with her
daughter it's atticus however who
returns back first
we don't know where or when he's been
but he comes back with a book called
lovecraft
country written by george freeman so it
looks like wherever he was
was an alternate time where george is
still alive and perhaps one in which
matt ruff doesn't write lovecraft
country but george does
upon hearing police sirens atticus
rushes out making sure to take the ori
ki
with him but it's the final shot of
diana freeman's name on the cover of
arithia blue
that's going to link this cop's murder
back to hippolyta and with racist
captain lancaster's men looking after
this place my guess
is that they won't be following the law
thanks for watching everyone make sure
to like and subscribe and leave a
comment below about what you thought of
the episode for more bad takes you can
follow me on twitter and instagram at
thinkstoryyt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much